oh they call you JLo Keva
yeah all right put the funnel in your
pants like that balance the coin on the
top and then you just got up Cap'n and
drop it into your thing
I hang blue Gothika look up you ready
yeah oh yeah I have a pair of pants and
I'd be happy to give them to JLo look
that beer on
I feel bad taking oh don't feel bad at
all these these are nice and fresh and
clean and I'll give you a nice
expression a pair of boxers to thank you
a great sport brother thank you for my
fan of course thank you
Thank You Love I'll get a doctor on pass
here yeah you want obviously what my
attention we love it natural wartime pet
that hey look at it my ability
Hey
- son
Scott you just got recognized for the
first time international star man I know
I just got recognized that the where are
we know what we'll gone
Brisby Bru Brisbane Affleck
this is where I shall be performing
Rihanna and Chris how long have you guys
been together
oh yes you just celebrated your Adriana
ver sory
yeah we have not opened up the doors to
the venue yet I'm here with the naked
magicians amen
and I hear that we're doing a stunt
that's it he's caught yeah let me show
you Cantrell I bet me Greg from the
count of three Chris is gonna throw the
cards free the year I'm gonna throw this
knot I don't know
here we go you guys have a good night
this is the kind of a mess out of my all
right you ever regret that there Brad oh
man Rory off to you now down
well Jason Bernie yeah okay cool
when did you get to the airport today oh
can apply yeah six are there is ladies
excited well wave ol big star can't
we've been planning this for weeks
yeah I just can't believe that the guys
shitty work on my butt cheek has been
recreated so many times yeah
it's a mess and it's a [ __ ] dick to
your foot to mess it was great would I
be a dick if I asked you to take off so
then Pete thought my baby has to take it
off - [ __ ]
thanks doc what's your hand dirt there
how'd you lose your leg motorbike that's
a good way to do it all right to watch
my previous blog click here we so good
and the next one's [ __ ] I [ __ ] up
good wait for that
holy [ __ ] so good